there is some guy some
poor sap some schlubby millennial
feminist girly man who made a
an instagram video
of him singing a song about how great
abortion is and how it's wonderful to
have abortions
that to it takes all of the dumbest
arguments and slogans and just
just puts them all condenses them all
into one minute take a listen
some folks believe a life begins when
eggmates sperm and wanna force all
pregnant women to carry to term but
their actions point to something that
you wouldn't expect that they think kids
only matter when they're not born yet
they'll make sure family leave and child
care funding fails take away their
parents at the border in jail kids beg
for climate action under crippling debt
while you show them they only matter
when they're not born yet
if abortion was the issue contraception
would reduce it
but wouldn't you know certain people
made it difficult for everyone to use it
wow
publicly shame them if they can't afford
lunch refuse to keep schools safe from
covid or guns for once i wish their
actions would disprove what i've said
that they think kids only matter when
they're not born yet
okay so this boils down to one slogan in
particular that you've heard
very ignorant leftists use for a long
time that republicans they're not
pro-life they're pro-birth
they're not for they only care about
kids when they're in the womb but then
they don't then they don't like kids or
something right so uh
he wants me to just be says i wish they
would disprove my point so okay let's
disprove the points this is a short
video let's go through every single one
of them this is guy oh you posted of
course he posted it on tik tok all the
stupidest stuff in the world i noticed
these days it's on tick tock you may
have noticed that the economy is going
completely insane these days and prices
are going way way up and income is not
going way way up and a lot of people are
worried about the direction of our
economy well one way to hedge your
investments is with physical gold now i
know what you're thinking michael i
can't i can't afford a physical gold or
physical precious metals you can you can
actually for as little as 30 a month no
i can't michael you're a liar before you
call me a liar check out what acre gold
is doing you subscribe to their gold
bars for thirty dollars a month
once your gold stash reaches the price
of their gold bars they will discreetly
ship acre gold to your door they've got
a new hundred dollar a month
subscription to a five grand gold bar i
love it i have really enjoyed investing
in physical precious metals and in acre
gold right now you can go visit acre
gold dot com slash knowles k-w-l-e-s
start investing in physical gold today
make sure you go to that url because
acre is giving away a gold bar to
qualify for the giveaway tweeter post
why you should be the recipient and
mention at get underscore acre that is
get acre gold dot com slash knowles
thank you acre gold for supporting the
show let's roll the tape
some folks believe a life begins when
eggmates spots
that is not just what some folks believe
that is what
the science says
when when egg meets sperm that creates a
life it has all of the characteristics
of a life and it is not merely a part of
the father or of the mother as a sperm
or an egg cell might be but it creates a
new unique human being with a unique
genetic code that will continue to grow
that begins to grow and that continues
to grow into a human being until his
death they will continue to grow in that
same sort of process with that same
genetic code in that same unique
identity and life
until their death so it's not just what
some people believe that's what everyone
believes including a lot of uh
pro-abortion people by the way the
honest pro-abortion people the only
people who don't believe that are
ignorant or stupid or both continue
and want to force all pregnant women to
carry to terms
they want to force all pregnant women to
carry to term
that's one way to frame it
the other way to frame it is
some people believe that life begins at
conception namely
every person with eyes and ears and two
functioning brain cells and so we don't
think you should be able to kill that
person
for whatever reason just willy-nilly
that you should not be able to kill
innocent babies correct move on
their actions point to something that
you wouldn't expect that they think kids
only matter when they're not born yet
so this is his thesis
we've established i think the kids
matter
when they're in the womb
he seems to be implying that the left
doesn't believe kids matter when they're
in the womb and his thesis is they only
met they don't matter at all afterwards
okay why not
they'll make sure family leave and child
care funding fails take away their
parents at the border
so first of all a lot of a lot of
republicans and conservatives uh support
family leave sorts of policies don't
forget the trump administration was
pushing one even if you don't support
family leave policies one of the reasons
that people don't support that is they
don't want the government and the state
to grow to take over the raising of
children because we believe that the
family should take care of children so
we certainly support an economy that
allows a mother to stay home with her
child for instance we certainly support
an economic policy that encourages
people to have families
we certainly support local communities
helping to raise up kids we certainly
support even even the most mainstream
you know
chamber of commerce republican supports
child tax care credits for instance but
i i also think it's just an outdated
talking point because so many
conservatives these days are pushing for
explicitly pro-family policies look at
what victor orban is doing in hungary
look how which is encouraging the growth
of families and look at how many
conservatives support those kind of
policies here we've now become sort of
hungary-philic over here in the the
united states because we want that kind
of policy so it's also just dated kind
of rhetoric keep going it's begged for
climate action under crippling death
while you show them they only matter
when they're not born yet
pause so he says you're going to put
your your you're going to throw the
parents in jail and separate them from
the kids first of all that's not a
republican policy that policy began
under bill clinton it continued under
barack obama the left only cared about
it under donald trump and now it's
continuing to happen under joe biden but
but even beyond that what we're saying
is don't come here yes stay with your
family stay with your family and your
country because we don't want to
separate anybody and we don't we we
can't just have open borders continue
abortion was the issue contraception
would reduce it
that's not true that isn't true so there
is no evidence that contraception
actually reduces abortion obviously
since the growth of contraception you've
seen an increase in the abortion rate
during the 20th century nearly all these
are according to a number of studies
99.1 percent of sexually experienced
women in the u.s have used contraception
at some point so everyone has access to
conception and basically everyone uses
it at some point 48 of women with
unintended pregnancies were using
contraception in the month they
conceived about half of pregnancies
ended by abortion occur during the use
of contraceptives 10 of women using
reversible forms of contraception become
pregnant over 12 months of use and among
women at risk of unintended pregnancy 89
use contraception so that talking point
just complete complete bs even though
even though god reception is available
to everyone complete bs keep going
but wouldn't you know certain people
made it difficult for everyone to use it
wow
publicly shame them if they can't afford
lunch refuse to keep schools safe from
covid or guns
kids aren't at risk from covid in any
particular way i i'm not saying they
have a zero percent risk but they have a
very very very low risk from coronavirus
all of the science agrees with that in
terms of uh guns
we went through the numbers the other
day but people are at a far greater risk
of dying from knives and from clubs and
from hammers and bats than they are from
ar-15s or really guns of any sort other
than
if you're talking about democrat-run
cities with gang violence with pistols
with all sorts of illegal uh weapons but
again you can't you can't really blame
conservatives for that can you keep
going once i wish their actions would
disprove what i've said that they think
kids only matter when they're not born
yet
not only have we disproved what you said
with our facts and logic but also i
think with our actions we have
conservatives are much more likely to
donate to charity uh conservatives
obviously are pushing a lot of crisis
pregnancy centers and conservatives are
are very likely to
support adoption and there are 36
couples willing to adopt every new baby
in america who's put up for adoption
complete b
s it just shows you that big difference
between the appearance what we're told
from the left the narratives that we're
told by the ruling class
and the reality of the situation and
when people wake up to it
it is almost shocking to see the lies
that we're all living in i'm so glad you
enjoyed that clip that makes me feel
really good if you want to catch the
whole show you can do it here ring the
bell subscribe on youtube you get the
whole show here or if you don't want to
be censored quite as much as we are
sometimes by our friends over here then
you can go to apple podcast spotify
stitch or google play wherever you get
your podcasts for free and subscribe to
the michael knowles show go do it maybe
leave a five star review that'd be nice
i'd appreciate it we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]